[Applause]
hello everyone this is an interesting
topic I would like to share with you
some of the panel action today on
Twitter this thing called the chest the
full English breakfast a chess podcast
with a couple of chitchat what's it all
about here we have this this dude here
a colleague Peterson with a Content
director for stress 24 we have
international chess master lore and
strength who is on a mission to get the
most talented minds the recognition they
deserve and of course the ginger game
Simon Williams who is all in all a great
guy and you know strings are awesome and
the YouTube channel is pretty cool and
they have this thing called here the
full English breakfast and they're
already at their 44th episode and this
is the first time I ever heard about it
so I've only watched their latest
episode the one with former world
champion holy fun talking about sexism
in chess and final round processed in
Gibraltar and all in all it's a it's a
great podcast it's a great episode and
you know I'm interesting that kind of
stuff and I really learned a lot you
know and you have I don't know I checked
all the other ones and all the topics
seem on point you know here we have
agony unlimited it's a it's a wordplay
you know how Aegon Aegon they they kind
of found that to agony unlimited if
you're familiar right with the Aegon and
the problem they're causing here we have
a
the one with the rather slow voice
effect only so I'll listen to one short
clip from this episode where erratic
explain to them how to graph is the
first and last name and here we have
hair broads also an interesting topic in
the chess world and yeah there's were
what we saw win the United States
Championship so I was very glad to come
about to come upon this and I don't know
I just wanted to share it with y'all
so here you can read all about them you
can follow them on Twitter here are
their personal pages and this is their
official full English breakfast page
nice amount of followers they have and I
put the buildings of all of these in the
description below so you don't have to
search for it it's you know just watch
one episode actual you'll be very
pleased I know I was so this is thank
you all for watching and see you soon
[Music]